We're on problem 19.
If k, n, x, and y are positive
numbers satisfying-- let's
see, what did they write?
They wrote x to the minus 4/3 is
equal to k to the minus 2.
y to the positive 4/3 is
equal to n squared.
What is xy to the minus 2/3
in terms of n and k?
All right, so we just have to
rewrite this in terms of n and
k, so let me write it big.
So xy to the minus 2/3, that
equals x to the minus 2/3,
times y to the minus 2/3.
We know what x to the 4/3 is.
This is what I wrote here, it
might not be that legible.
Sorry.
So this is a 4, right?
We know what x to the
minus 4/3 is.
So can we rewrite this as x to
the minus 4/3 to something?
Well, sure.
We can rewrite this term, right
here, we can write this
as-- let me write it right below
it so you don't get too
confused-- as x to the minus
4/3, and then you raise that
to the 1/2 power.
This is the same
thing as this.
How do I know that?
Well, if I multiply 4/3 times
1/2-- because I'm raising
something to an exponent, and
then that to an exponent-- if
I multiply minus 4/3 times 1/2,
I get minus 2/3, right?
This 2 cancels out, this
becomes a 2, and
this is what I get.
You can try it out.
Similarly, I want to write this
second term-- I'm going
to do it in green-- this
y to the minus 2/3.
I know what y to the
4/3 is, right?
So I want to write it as y to
the 4/3 to some other power.
So 4/3 times what is
equal to minus 2/3?
Well, 4/3 times minus 1/2.
And you can try it out.
4/3 times minus 1/2 is equal
to minus 2/3, right?
A positive times a negative
equals a negative.
And then the 4 and the
2 end up just the
2-- sorry, I'm burping.
So what does this become?
Well, we know what x to the
minus 4/3 is, right? x to the
minus 4/3 is equal to
k to the minus 2.
So that first term is equal to
this, is equal to k-- that's
too dark-- k to the minus 2, and
then we're raising that to
the 1/2-- right, that's the
same 1/2 right there-- and
then y to the 4/3.
What's y to the 4/3?
Well, that's n squared.
And then that's, of course,
the minus 1/2.
And then we can multiply.
What's minus 2 times 1/2?
Well, it's just minus 1.
So it's k to the minus 1.
And then what's 2
times minus 1/2?
It's minus 1 again.
So k to the minus 1,
n to the minus 1.
And that's the same thing
as 1/kn, or 1/nk,
which is choice A.
And I just realized that there's
actually an easier way
to do that.
We could've done it like this,
we could have just said-- let
me see, let me erase this stuff,
because it's, I think,
good for you to know the easier
way, instead of the way
I just showed you
how to do it.
Let me erase all of this.
I think we would've
saved some steps,
and been more intuitive.
Let me erase all of this, I just
wanted to keep what I had
written before.
Erase, erase, erase.
OK, I think that's
good enough.
You can just ignore the
stuff on the right.
So we could've simplified
these ahead of time.
We could have said, x to the
minus 4/3 is equal to k
to the minus 2.
If we raised both of these
to the 1/2 power,
we would get what?
Minus 4/3 times 1/2 is-- we
would have gotten x to the
minus 2/3 is equal to-- what's
negative 2 times 1/2?
It's negative 1, right?
It would've equaled k
to the negative 1.
And similarly, if we had raised
y to the 4/3 equals n
squared, if we'd raised both of
those to the minus 1/2-- if
you do something on one side of
the equation, you just have
to do it on the other-- then you
would have gotten y to the
minus 2/3 is equal to
n to the minus 1.
And then this would have been
really easy to solve.
xy to the minus 2/3 is the same
thing as x to the minus
2/3, times y to the minus 2/3.
x to the the minus 2/3
is k to the minus 1.
And y to the negative 2/3
is n to the minus 1.
So it would have been k to the
minus 1, n to the minus 1.
That's 1/nk.
Well, I guess in hindsight I can
say this was easier, but
the way we did it would've also
worked, and you really
don't know sometimes which one
will be the shortcut when you
do it the first time.
But either way could've
worked.
You could've simplified ahead of
time, if you had seen that
you wanted to get it into
2/3, not 4/3, because
they had a 2/3 here.
Or you could just go the way
we did it the first time,
either way works.
Next problem, problem
number 20.
OK, functions of f and g.
So I'm going to have to do some
drawing here, if we have
enough time.
So I have to draw two of them.
That one's going to be
for f, and this one's
going to be for g.
What points are there?
So f of x-- let's see,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
f of x is 2 points back, and
it intersects there.
And it intersects at the point
minus 1 comma 1, 2, 3, so it
intersects here.
And then it goes through
the origin.
And then it goes
to 1, minus 3.
So that's 1, 2, 3, 1,
so it goes here.
And then it goes at 2 comma
0, and it intersects here.
So let me try to draw that.
So the graph looks something
like this.
It goes up, it intersects this
point, comes down through the
origin, goes down here, and
then goes up like that.
That is y equals f of x.
Now what does g of x do?
g of x goes to 2 comma 1.
So 1, 2 comma 1.
Then it's to 4, minus 5.
So 2, 3, 4, 1, 2, 3,
4, 5-- 4, minus 5.
And then it goes back up.
So it looks something
like this.
It goes down, goes up like that,
goes back up like that.
The figures above show
the graph of the
functions f and g.
The function f is defined by--
so this one-- f of x is equal
to x to the third minus 4x.
The function g of x is equal
to f of x plus h, plus k,
where h and k are constants.
What is the value of k?
So essentially, what they're
saying is, g of x is f of x
shifted up or down by some
value, k, right?
Because when you add a constant
to a function, you're
just moving it up or down
by some value, k.
And when you add h, that means
you're shifting it to-- let me
make sure I get this right-- so
if it was x minus h, that
means you're shifting it
to the right by h.
So x plus h means you're
shifting it to the left by h.
So k is the easy one.
This point corresponds
to this point.
So how much did we shift down?
This is the point negative
1 comma 3.
And this is the point
2 comma 1.
So we went from y equals
3 to y equals 1, right?
So we shifted down by 2.
So k is going to be minus 2.
And similarly you could
do it with this point.
So k is equal to minus 2.
Now we have to figure out how
much we shifted left to right.
So [? similarly, ?]
these are the corresponding
points, because you can look
at them in the graph.
So we went from minus
1 to positive 2.
So we shifted to
the right by 3.
And you could do the same thing
with this point here at
the bottom.
We shifted to the right by 3.
So if I wanted to shift f of x
to the right by 3, I would
write it like this,
f of x minus 3.
That's how I would shift a
function to the right by 3.
They're saying plus h, so
h has to be minus 3.
h is minus 3.
And minus 3 times minus 2?
Well, that's positive 6,
which is choice E.